turning now to the fight over covid
vaccine mandates with american lives
really on the line here at least eight
states have bans of some kind on such
mandates either on vaccine requirements
or
on businesses that are requiring proof
of vaccination that includes the state
of montana where medical providers are
now suing as hospitals there are just
overrun they say they cannot keep
patients safe if they're required to
employ unvaccinated workers meg oliver
is outside billings clinic that's the
state's largest hospital meg good
morning to you
gail good morning montana is the only
state in the country that bans companies
from requiring vaccinations for
employees but as hospital beds like here
fill up fast the push for more people to
get the shot is critical
we're bursting at the seams right now
emergency room dr jamie belski can
barely keep up with the crush of new
covet patients
here at billings clinic the icu is
running at 150 percent capacity the
hospital has built makeshift rooms along
hallways like this and called in the
national guard for support here in
yellowstone county just over 50 percent
of the population is vaccinated i
struggled with it
being on the ventilator 59 year old
frank miller was hospitalized with covet
and has been in the hospital for more
than 17 days the unvaccinated engineer
spent more than a week on a ventilator
how scared were you
oh scared out of my mind you were scared
out of your mind
what did you think was going to happen
because you don't know
you don't know what's happening
afterwards
i thought i'd come right out of it and
i'd be okay
and all of a sudden i couldn't move my
hands
i couldn't feed myself
scenes like this are playing out across
montana with younger and sicker patients
admitted daily in the past week the
state averaged about 109 coveted
patients hospitalized in the icu per day
breaking the record seen during the fall
of 2020. have you reached your breaking
point yet
i think all of us have reached breaking
points at different times you have good
days you have bad days i have days i
have to call my college buddies and say
hey man it's been a it's been a bad day
we lost a tough patient last night and
they're great about coming up and saying
hey what can we do if the vaccination
rate does not increase how scared are
you for the future i'm petrified for the
future if the vaccination rate doesn't
increase this is going to get worse
we're going to run out of ventilators
again
in the last week eight people have died
here from covid related symptoms frank
regrets not getting the vaccine and
plans to do so he stood up for the first
time yesterday in 17 days but he still
has a long road ahead he has to go to a
rehab center where he will learn to walk
again and feed himself before eventually
returning home
thank you to our central workers or as i
like to call them superheroes meg i
appreciate you